take a look at this it's the
Thanksgiving Day Parade route here in
New York City Millions uh lining up to
enjoy the spectacle this Year's parade
features 16 giant character balloons 28
floats and 12 marching bands as well as
a partridge in a pear tree entertainment
tonight's Kevin Frazier and Kelty Knight
are hosting the Thanksgiving Day Parade
here on CBS they join us now from the
parade route notes in hand jackets on
um Kevin and Kelty when I covered this
parade uh three years ago I was stunned
that there was a coordination between
the floats the balloons the live music
and the bands that walk down the street
what's jumping out to you and how are
things there this morning well first of
all Mother Nature is what's jumping out
she has cooperated it is a spectacular
day in the city I mean look it's cold
enough to Still Rock a scarf but it is
glorious no gloves it is amazing and as
you know this parade just the spectacle
of how big the balloons and the floats
and the excitement on the streets are
lined with folks we're ready we're ready
and this is such an exciting holiday
tradition this is really a time when
watching us and we get to celebrate
together and we're just honored to be
able to spend this day with everyone at
home yeah
you guys do this every single year I
know it doesn't ever get old but no I I
hear you're going to be doing a little
cooking this year am I right about that
first of all I'm still waiting on an
invitation to your house for some
Thanksgiving Day cooking okay
Michelle
okay now we've cleared that up yes we
are giving you everything a little
cooking a little shopping and the new
floats um and all I'm glad you're about
to become a Dad congratulations honey
we're so happy for you and there's
something that's going to be playing
friends it's there's good something is
going to be playing non-stop in your
house when this baby arrives is baby
shark and this year we have a baby shark
balloon new to the party room so get
ready Dad it's a float and Ziggy Marley
will be on it so we're excited to see
Ziggy Ziggy's has his um boys with them
on the float so that'll be one of the
cool things Jordin Sparks um Jimmy
Fallon uh will also see Dionne Warwick
the new queen of Twitter she will be
here I'm sure she'll be tweeting I can't
believe it she rolls down the parade
route there are lots of stars always and
we're very excited
no no sorry sorry I don't mean to cut
the vibe it's always hard when it's
remote I was gonna say you guys are
talking about all the incredible
performers that are going to be there at
the parade and Kelsey I wanted to ask
you about your favorite floats because I
as a kid I always love seeing these are
going to date me a little bit but I
always love seeing Superman and Underdog
and Popeye the Sailor Man I'm sure half
of America at least the young ones are
like who is he talking about but I'm
sure they're not making an appearance
this year
can we get Underdog back I came as I
remember underdogs are the cartoon still
on
it's a great question I love all of this
on our CBS coverage this morning we have
two Broadway musicals performing six and
Moulin Rouge and as a former Radio City
Rockette and Broadway girl I love to see
the Broadway performances I feel like
it's such an homage to New York City to
be able to show fans at home something
from inside one of those theaters so to
me that's the most exciting and then
grogu balloon obviously I'm a big
Mandalorian fan and when you see little
baby Yoda who's not so baby here at the
parade it's amazing oh and don't forget
Dirks Bentley Dierks Bentley performing
also today so another one of the
performances that we have coming for you
just special
um is a part of this parade and it
really goes to show you there is a
little something for everyone when it
comes to the Thanksgiving Day Parade
Kevin Frazier and Kelty night great to
see you both enjoy the day everyone can
see the Thanksgiving Day Parade here on
CBS
[Laughter]
all right
and with that we will be right back